after traveling thousands of kilometers
these migrants have crossed the Rio
Grand between Mexico and the United
States some say the hardest part of
their Journey was through
Mexico they take our money they hit
women and children they don't care about
anything Mexican police and immigration
authorities are chasing us they don't
care if they crash against us or if a
train runs us over they are causing
accidents Mexican security forces are
imposing tougher measures to try and
hold back back record numbers of
migrants attempting The
Crossing Mexican authorities police
immigration officers and army want to
charge us up to $120 to let us pass what
happens then the Mexican authorities are
mistreating the migrants how is that
humanitarian these people are being
taken to southern Mexico by plane as
part of a repatriation plan extra
measures have begun after Mexican
president Andres Manuel Lopez orador and
US president Jo Biden met to discuss
curbing numbers of migrants at the
border it got saturated and became a
problem and they had to Halt transport
and shut down the Border but we're
already solving it the agreement is to
keep working together we have a proposal
to boost our plans many of those
attempting to cross the border are
fleeing violence poverty and other
crisis in their home Nations but with
the Biden Administration and Mexico out
to restrict their numbers making that
trip is likely to get even harder imin
Kima Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer